(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Chegamos então ao módulo 3.
Esse módulo vai ser dedicado exclusivamente ao estudo
do leilão judicial.
Nós vamos falar sobre tudo o que você
precisa saber para participar de uma forma segura
de um leilão judicial.
Como nós já falamos no módulo 1, o
leilão judicial, ele acontece no decorrer de um
processo judicial.
Então, alguém, que é o devedor, foi condenado
dentro de um processo judicial a pagar uma
quantia para outra pessoa.
Pode ser que esse devedor, ele não tenha
essa quantia em dinheiro.
Então, a lei estabelece aquela ordem de preferência
dos bens do devedor que vão ser usados
para pagar determinada quantia.
O leilão de imóveis, então, dentro de um
processo judicial, tem essa finalidade, tem a finalidade
de transformar um imóvel desse devedor em dinheiro
para que aquela quantia determinada em um processo
judicial seja paga.
Qualquer juiz pode determinar que um imóvel vale
a leilão judicial.
A gente tem os leilões judiciais realizados pela
Justiça Estadual, que é chamado de Justiça Comum,
pela Justiça Federal e pela Justiça do Trabalho.
Como é que você vai saber qual é
a justiça que está levando o imóvel a
determinado leilão?
É muito simples, você vai olhar no edital
do leilão e o edital do leilão, ele
vai conter essa informação de quem é a
ordem para realizar aquele leilão.
Vai ter o nome do juiz e o
tribunal ao qual aquele juiz está vinculado.
Eu queria deixar um pedido para todos os
meus alunos que não são da área jurídica.
Não criem alguma forma de bloqueio com o
leilão judicial por considerar, às vezes, que os
termos que os advogados e os juízes usam
em processo judicial possam ser muito difíceis.
A gente vai passar por todos os detalhes
aqui nesse módulo, sobre tudo que você precisa
saber.
A gente vai ter uma aula específica onde
eu vou falar detalhadamente cada termo que você
pode encontrar na análise de um edital e
de uma matrícula em um leilão judicial.
Então a gente vai explicar termos como fração
ideal, usufruto, hipoteca, direitos sobre o imóvel e
mais alguns termos.
Isso tudo vai ficar bem detalhado para vocês
dentro de cada aula específica.
Pode ser que no primeiro momento você não
consiga decorar todos esses termos, que você tenha
alguma dificuldade ao se deparar com esse termo
no edital ou na matrícula do leilão.
Pode ser que você lembre que você já
estudou aquele termo, mas você não lembra especificamente
o que significa aquele termo.
E aí você tem a tranquilidade de assistir
quantas vezes você quiser as aulas aqui do
curso.
As aulas, como eu falei, elas são vitalícias.
Então, a partir do momento que você encontra
um termo que você não lembra o que
aquele termo significa, é só você voltar na
aula específica daquele termo e aí você vai
conseguir relembrar.
Eventual dificuldade inicial que exista contra esses termos,
ela vai ficando diluída quanto mais a gente
estuda.
Isso acontece com qualquer matéria e não seria
diferente em matéria de leilão judicial.
Então, quanto mais você estuda, mais rápida vai
ficar a sua análise.
Quanto mais você estuda, mais fácil você vai
saber se você deve descartar um leilão ou
continuar analisando aquele leilão.
Existem leilões que eu bato o olho e
falo esse leilão aqui eu não vou perder
um minuto olhando pra ele.
E existem outros que, numa análise inicial, eu
passo a estudar mais a fundo se os
requisitos que a lei exige para que um
leilão judicial seja realizado foram ou não cumpridos
naquele determinado processo.
Então, pra gente fazer uma análise completa de
um leilão judicial, a gente precisa ter acesso
àquele processo judicial que deu origem àquele leilão.
E como é que você vai ter acesso
a esse processo judicial?
Em primeiro lugar, existem dois tipos de processos.
Processos físicos e os processos eletrônicos.
Os processos físicos, hoje em dia, eles não
existem mais basicamente, mas ainda existem processos mais
antigos que ainda estão ocorrendo e esses processos,
se eram físicos, continuam físicos.
Mas a regra hoje em dia é que
o processo vai ser eletrônico, que você não
tem que comparecer a um cartório judicial para
ter acesso àquele processo.
Mas então, retomando, para um processo físico, basta
que você compareça àquele cartório especificamente onde está
aquele processo, só pra gente explicar um pouco.
Os tribunais, eles são divididos em alguns fóruns
e esses fóruns, eles têm varas judiciais.
Então, cada fórum tem essa vara judicial.
Essa divisão depende muito do tamanho do tribunal.
Existem tribunais maiores, como os tribunais de justiça
de São Paulo, os tribunais de justiça do
Rio de Janeiro, que eles vão ter várias
varas.
Cada processo está vinculado a uma vara específica.
Quando você localizar o número do processo judicial,
você pode pesquisar qual é a vara que
está naquele processo.
Então, para o processo físico, você vai localizar
o número daquele processo judicial que está ocorrendo,
você vai fazer isso através da matrícula e
você pode comparecer pessoalmente ao fórum onde está
aquela vara desse processo judicial que você quer
analisar e analisar esse processo lá mesmo na
vara.
As varas, elas geralmente têm um balcão, você
pode pegar o processo e olhar nesse balcão,
pode folhear o processo e pode tirar fotos
desse processo.
Você não vai poder retirar esse processo da
vara.
Então, o que eu recomendo é que você,
além de analisar o processo ali pessoalmente, você
fotografe o que te interessa, porque aí você
vai ter como visualizar o que você fotografou
em qualquer momento, bastando que esteja com o
seu celular ali presente.
E os processos eletrônicos, você não consegue visualizar
comparecendo a um fórum, você tem que visualizar
pela internet.
E aí você vai se perguntar, como é
que eu vou fazer isso se eu não
sou advogado?
A regra é que qualquer advogado pode ter
acesso a um processo eletrônico, não precisa ser
o advogado que está envolvido diretamente naquele processo.
Então, a regra é que os processos, eles
sejam públicos.
Tanto é por isso que você, mesmo não
sendo advogado, pode comparecer ao fórum para visualizar
um processo físico.
A mesma regra de processo público se aplica
para o processo eletrônico, mas os autos desse
processo eletrônico, eles só vão estar disponíveis para
advogados visualizarem.
E aí, como eu falei, não precisa ser
o advogado específico que esteja envolvido naquele processo,
de nenhuma daquelas partes daquele processo.
Qualquer advogado vai conseguir ter acesso àquele processo
eletrônico.
Então, pode ser que você não tenha um
advogado que possa te fazer isso a favor,
ou até mesmo que você tenha algum advogado
conhecido, bem próximo, mas que você não queira
pedir nenhum favor.
E eu vou deixar aqui uma recomendação de
um site que ele tem cadastrado vários correspondentes
jurídicos.
Esses correspondentes jurídicos, eles se juntam com as
bancadas que trarão nesse site para realizar serviços
em cidades diferentes da qual aquele advogado que
está responsável por um processo realmente atua.
Então, por exemplo, eu atuo aqui em São
Paulo, eu poderia contratar um correspondente jurídico para
resolver alguma coisa para mim no Rio de
Janeiro ou na Bahia, justamente porque é mais
fácil contratar esse correspondente jurídico do que viajar
para o Rio de Janeiro ou para a
Bahia.
Só que esses correspondentes jurídicos, eles também estão
ali para aceitar basicamente qualquer trabalho jurídico que
exista.
Então, você pode solicitar o serviço de um
correspondente jurídico e pedir para ele baixar, fazer
o download de um processo específico que você
queira analisar e ele vai te mandar esse
download por e-mail.
Sabendo analisar o processo, então, você vai ter
todas as informações que você precisa por esse
e-mail que você vai responder, porque você
vai ter o processo completo e aí, a
partir do processo completo, você faz a análise
do que a gente vai ver que é
necessário para participar ou não de um leilão
judicial.
Vou mostrar aqui um pouco como é que
funciona esse site.
Então, o site está aberto, é correspondente.smigalha
.com.br. O link também vai ficar aqui
na descrição da aula.
Esses planos e valores aqui não servem para
quem quer solicitar um serviço.
Esses planos e valores são para quem quer
se cadastrar como correspondente jurídico.
Então, você como solicitante, você não paga nada.
Vou fazer aqui uma busca por São Paulo
e vocês vão ver que vão abrir vários
correspondentes jurídicos que atuam aqui em São Paulo.
Temos aqui, então, 690 resultados encontrados para São
Paulo.
E aí, eu queria fazer uma observação.
Pode ser que você esteja analisando um leilão
judicial de um imóvel do interior, que aquele
processo seja no interior e não na capital
de um estado.
Por exemplo, você pode analisar um leilão judicial
que vai acontecer em Campinas.
Não necessariamente você precisa de um advogado de
Campinas para que ele faça esse download do
processo eletrônico para você.
Você pode usar tranquilamente qualquer advogado que esteja
aqui no Migalhas cadastrado em São Paulo, capital,
que esse advogado tranquilamente vai ter acesso aos
processos que ocorram na capital do estado de
São Paulo e aos processos do interior, porque
o Tribunal de Justiça, ele tem um sistema
unificado.
Então, a partir do momento que o advogado
tem acesso a um processo judicial da capital,
ele tranquilamente pode ter do interior também.
Quando vocês forem fazer essa pesquisa de algum
advogado correspondente, fiquem atentos a essa informação de
certificado digital, porque essa informação de certificado digital
é o que possibilita, muitas vezes, um advogado
ter acesso pleno a um processo eletrônico.
Então, basta que você use aqui o site,
você não precisa nem solicitar o serviço diretamente
pelo site.
Você pode ver o telefone da pessoa e
entrar em contato direto no telefone da pessoa.
A título de curiosidade, eu fiz um levantamento
aqui de cinco advogados que escolhi de forma
aleatória aqui no Migalhas, em São Paulo, para
saber qual era o preço médio que eles
iam cobrar.
Um advogado falou que não cobraria nada e
esse aí a gente descarta, porque se for
uma coisa recorrente, obviamente, esse advogado não vai
fazer sempre de graça.
Então, vamos ficar com os outros quatro que
me passaram o orçamento.
O orçamento mais barato que eu tive foi
R$15,00 e o orçamento mais caro
que eu tive foi R$60,00.
Então, eu recebi orçamentos entre R$15,00
e R$60,00 para fazer download de
processos que eu havia pedido para que esse
advogado me mandasse por e-mail.
O que é esse valor, perto de o
que uma consultoria de leilão cobraria para fazer
essa análise que você vai aprender a fazer
aqui no curso?
Absolutamente nada.
Eu já falei várias vezes que uma consultoria
especializada em leilão cobra de 7 a 10
% do valor da arrematação.
Então, vamos imaginar aqui um apartamento que você
vai arrematar por R$300,000.
Geralmente, o mais barato que você vai pagar
em uma consultoria vai ficar em torno de
R$21,000.
Você pagar R$60,00 para analisar um
processo não significa nada no valor da sua
arrematação.
Então, por isso que eu volto a reforçar.
É muito interessante que você aprenda esse processo
de arrematar para que você possa fazer arrematações
ainda mais lucrativas, porque você vai se livrar
dessa consultoria.
Então, para você ter acesso aqui a um
processo eletrônico, é muito simples.
Basta que você utilize esse serviço de correspondentes
jurídicos aqui do Miguelhas.
E uma informação, você também pode usar esse
serviço de correspondentes jurídicos para fazer uma consulta
a um processo físico.
Vamos supor, aqui na cidade de São Paulo
existem vários fóruns.
Eu moro em um determinado bairro.
Às vezes, para eu me locomover a um
fórum mais distante, se eu for de Uber,
eu vou pagar mais caro do que eu
pagaria para um colega fazer esse serviço de
ir lá e fotografar o processo para mim.
Então, o mesmo vale para você.
Pode ser que você esteja numa cidade e
vá avaliar um leilão judicial de um imóvel
em outra cidade.
Use o serviço de correspondentes jurídicos.
Só que como vai ser um processo físico,
aí eu recomendo que você realmente busque o
correspondente jurídico direto naquela cidade, e não que
você utilize qualquer advogado que atue naquele estado,
porque vai ser uma cidade específica.
O advogado daquela cidade específica, com certeza, vai
te cobrar muito menos para fazer esse serviço.
Queria deixar ainda uma informação que eu falei
que a regra de um processo judicial é
que o processo judicial, ele seja público, mas
sempre existe exceção à regra.
E qual é a exceção à regra de
um processo judicial público?
É o processo judicial que corre em segredo
de justiça.
Esse processo judicial que corre em segredo de
justiça é bem exceção mesmo.
Alguns casos que podem ser decretados em segredo
de justiça, processos que envolvam pensão alimentícia, processos
que envolvam divórcio, processos de uma maneira geral
que envolvam matérias relacionadas ao direito de família
e qualquer outro processo que o juiz entenda
que possa ter dados muito sensíveis e que
devem, em sua totalidade, ocorrer em segredo de
justiça, porque nada impede que um processo público
o juiz determine que determinado documento vai ficar
em segredo porque aquele documento tem informações muito
sensíveis das pessoas que estão envolvidas naquele processo.
Por exemplo, não é agradável que se você
participe de um processo e nesse processo você
tem que apresentar a sua declaração de imposto
de renda, não é agradável que toda pessoa
tenha acesso a sua declaração de imposto de
renda.
Essa declaração de imposto de renda, ela traz
dados muito sensíveis sobre a pessoa, traz dados
como a renda, tudo aquilo que a pessoa
tem de patrimônio, então não é interessante deixar
esse processo público, mas nada impede que o
processo seja público e aquele determinado documento que
apresenta a sua declaração de imposto de renda
o juiz determine em segredo, mas existem os
processos que como um todo vão correr em
segredo, todo o processo vai correr em segredo
de justiça.
E o que significa falar que o processo
corre em segredo de justiça?
Significa falar que as partes e os advogados
daquelas partes envolvidas no processo têm acesso àquele
processo judicial, mas ninguém que esteja interessado em
algum imóvel que foi determinado leilão dentro de
um processo judicial em segredo de justiça vai
ter acesso àquele processo, nem mesmo que esses
interessados em fazer a arrematação daquele imóvel sejam
advogados, porque só tem acesso a um processo
em segredo de justiça os advogados das partes
e como a gente já estudou os advogados
das partes do processo eles são por lei
proibidos de participar de leilão daquele processo especificamente,
então eles só não podem participar daquele processo
em que eles atuam.
Então nesse caso de processo que corre em
segredo de justiça, o imóvel ele vai a
leilão de qualquer maneira e as pessoas interessadas
não vão deixar de arrematar o imóvel porque
não tiveram acesso à documentação daquele processo elas
vão analisar normalmente a matrícula e o edital
do leilão e se acharem aquele imóvel ele
é interessante elas vão arrematar e só depois
da arrematação que elas terão acesso a esse
processo, porque uma vez arrematando o imóvel, o
arrematante ele deve entrar naquele processo que determinou
o leilão, porque essa vai ser a forma
de ele conseguir a desocupação daquele imóvel, vamos
ter uma aula específica aqui nesse módulo para
estudar sobre a desocupação do leilão judicial.
Então essa é uma observação importante, porque veja,
eu falei que o recomendado é que você
analise o processo judicial para saber se todos
os crâmios foram seguidos mas acabei de falar
também que existe uma exceção e essa exceção
é o processo que corre em segredo de
justiça, não importa quem seja interessado em participar
do leilão de um processo de segredo de
justiça, nem mesmo que ele seja advogado, ele
vai ter acesso ao conteúdo do que aconteceu
naquele processo, ele não vai ter acesso a
informação alguma daquele processo e mesmo assim as
pessoas fazem arrematações nesse caso, mas é importante
que você tenha em mente que a regra
sempre é analisar o que aconteceu naquele processo
judicial que está levando o imóvel ao leilão,
tenha isso em mente e isso vai te
trazer muito mais segurança, porque você tem muito
mais segurança de arrematar o imóvel daquilo que
você sabe que está acontecendo naquele processo, daquilo
que você sabe que as pessoas estão alegando
naquele processo, se alguém tentou impedir ou não
o leilão daquele processo, isso tudo são informações
muito válidas como a gente vai estudar aqui
nesse módulo, mas saiba que se você se
deparar com o processo de segredo de justiça,
não impede que você faça uma arrematação, desde
que você faça uma análise completa do edital,
do leilão, da matrícula do imóvel e da
viabilidade daquele leilão, se realmente aquele leilão ele
pode gerar um lucro, se seu objetivo for
investimento ou se o objetivo for moradia, se
realmente aquele imóvel é um bom imóvel para
moradia.
Já vou deixar aqui nessa aula alguns termos
frequentes que a gente vai encontrar analisando um
processo judicial que envolva um leilão judicial.
De um lado nós temos o exequente, que
também pode ser usado como sinônimo, autor ou
requerente.
Exequente, autor ou requerente é a parte que
está executando uma dívida, ou seja, é a
parte que tem direito a receber um dinheiro
de outra parte, então do lado nós temos
um exequente e do outro lado nós temos
um executado.
Executado você pode encontrar como sinônimo de executado,
réu ou requerido.
Executado, réu ou requerido é a parte que
deve pagar um valor a alguém.
Essa informação é muito importante para que você
possa diferenciar de cara quem é a parte
que tem direito a receber e quem é
a parte que tem que pagar algum valor.
Nas próximas aulas, então, desse modo nós vamos
analisar tudo que é necessário para participar de
um leilão judicial.